die 16 jährige kennt keine skrupel wenn
sie geld für alkohol zigaretten oder
partys braucht beklaute ihre mutter
herzlich willkommen zur neuen video
leute ja wenn ihr die letzten videos auf
einem kanal folgt ab und gesehen habt
welche anzahl an videos ich zu unserer
liebenswürdigen jenny bitte kurzen zwar
konnten die arbeiten gemacht habe und
hier auch die anderen jugendlichen in
diesem camp gesehen habt dann habt ihr
euch mit sicherheit gedacht sebastian
das war's dann einfach mal mit
geisteskranken teenager aus deutschland
das war längst nicht wirklich weiter
folgt dass inter durch forstleute und
ich habe ein sehr ähnliches format zu
endstation wildnis was man ein bisschen
angeschaut haben gefunden
dieses format heißt die strengsten
eltern der welt und es macht ihr relativ
ähnliche sachen schickt teenager die
sich sehr daneben benehmen als anrennen
der welt wo ich würde sagen wir öffnen
die bühne für zwei neue teenager die uns
mit ihrem fehlverhalten überzeugen
wollen und die erste person aus dieser
neuen reihe die sie uns vorstellen wird
ist ein junger mann namens pascal pascal
kevin aus hamm ist eine tickende
zeitbombe trinken kiffen schlägereien
die sonderschule schwänzt der 15-jährige
konsequent ok also wir haben zehn
sekunden vorstellungen von pascal ich
habe stehe und pascal außerdem passt
karl das gesagt was sagen also die
beschreiben dieser person grenzt schon
so an einfach so ein klischee saufen
kiffen sonderschule der teenie aus dem
ruhrpott hält sich für den super checker
wenn du mich dich zurück zu opfern
[Musik]
sehr gerne auf jeden fall wieso er so
anfängt so eine ansage zu machen und die
kamera zoomt so auf die drei
fragezeichen in dem sortiment
was soll das das kann warum bist du so
peter pascal es sich in der schule ist
heute morgen los gegangen
pascal kleine regeln und keine grenzen
soll da soldat also muss einfach sagen
dass kein junger mann der auf jeden fall
auf einen sehr geeigneten und geraden
weg direkt in die arbeitslosigkeit ist
also ich muss sagen bei diesen ganzen
formaten bin ich schon relativ
schockiert darüber wie krass bereit
diese jugendlichen sind einfach so
jegliche grenzen zu sprengen falls auch
alles scheiße stadtschule henkers
kaliber mit kumpel duell kippen und wie
ihr schon am frühen morgen das ist der
alltag der sonderschüler
er lebt einfach so dass live von einem
arbeitslosen alkoholiker mit 15
das ganze kontrastiert nur ein kleines
bisschen mit dem titel des videos derart
nämlich pascal der super checker aus dem
pott pascal an der stellung ich komme
immer an dich wie du dir bereits
frühmorgens bier und kippen super text
finde ich einfach bewundernswert
und sagt dass ich als baseballschläger
eine darüber ziehen würde
die firma macht verweilen habe ich das
glück habe ich es richtig gehört hat er
gesagt seine mutter geht ihm so auf den
sack dass er ihr gerne mit dem
baseballschläger 1
auch diese ebene von strecken überlegen
dass man so voll wie im fernsehen über
seine eigene mutter reden kann ist also
immer auch schon mal vor dass ich meine
frau waas doch er kommt einfach in die
haustür ein
seine mutter sagt du bist auch da er in
so nerven ich muss mal atmet neben ihm
nervlich mutter existiert einfach und
ist kein undurchsichtiger geist der in
jeden tag essen bringt nervlich stabiler
typ das war eine mutter will mama mama
du weißt doch dass mit der schule
das wird nicht funktionieren ich habe
einen anderen plan to mein leben ich bin
jetzt schon jeden tag im alkoholiker
camp okay ich werde damit voll
durchstarten ich werde
selbstständige alkoholiker wenn er
pascal so weiter macht glaube ich dass
da entweder irgendwann mal die polizei
hier steht und sagt er dich tot im kanal
oder straßen
jaja kann so passieren eines tages
polizei vor der tür
ingo mutter macht auch
ja sehr geehrte frau frau ihr sohn liegt
tot im straße ja also ich finde es
seltsam aber in die turmstraße werde ich
halt viel dass man dieser junge hat ein
plan also sagen er hat einfach er hat
einfach so ein gewisses eine gewisse
fülle an optionen mit denen arbeiten
kann sollte man im leben immer so machen
dass man nie eingleisig fertigen über
die mächtigen hat irgendwas anderes
ausreichen
pascal hier an der stelle hat müssen wir
darüber reden natürlich auch mehrere
optionen entweder selbstständige
alkoholiker oder hartz 4 und die folge
beste weniger als geil jeden morgen
aufzuwachen und nichts zu tun zu haben
keinen sinn im leben das gefühl zu haben
dass man den sozialstaat auf der tasche
liegt und kein produktiver bürger in
dieser gesellschaft ist einfach besser
leben als mit jobs zeit natürlich no hay
dann alle leute die aus welchen gründen
auch immer unfreiwillig inhalts wir sind
aber es soll ja aber so der einstellung
mutter jasmin ist am ende
mitreden er hat mich war und fast die
mutter merkt schon wieder da wie soll
das weitergehen
das aushalte größte teil als teenager
die mutter bringt
nur essen recht einen die wäsche räumt
das eigene zimmer auch sorgt
vollumfänglich für eine und man selbst
ist ein kleiner abriss der in seinem
leben oder nicht hinbekommen hat nein
das reicht nicht dann wird die eigene
mutter tatsächlich auch noch mit einem
reden menschen ziemlich abstoßend dass
die forscher von oskar leute aber es
geht weiter der mit pascal in dieser
folge ist eine junge dame namens sina
ihr vorstoß mit heißt einfach sina der
alptraum jeder mutter perfekt auch die
16 jährige sina ist der albtraum jeder
mutter ihr zimmer lässt die
hauptschülerin verdrecken regeln sind
ihr vollkommen egal
die sitzenbleiber in schwänzt ständig
den unterricht am alten warum liegt ein
ganzer bürger so dass nicht mehr
angemessen
hallo was für die
lebensmittelverschwendung also ich
meinem team genug wenn du den bürger
einfach noch anbeißen würdest und keine
anderen liegen würde aber ist nicht nur
angebissen
warum bestellt die bürger einfach nur so
zum rumliegen lassen
ja also ich würde sagen heute ist es
nicht so als wäre das eine gute
herangehensweise an den tag aber
hauptschülerin und geht nicht zur schule
sondern zu merkels ist immer noch besser
als sonderschüler und gehe ich zur
schule
und so hat sich das 1 3 aber ich weiß
nicht
ok vergessen was ich gesagt hab auch
chinas zwölfjähriger bruder rahim leidet
unter den täglichen gewaltausbrüchen
seiner großen schwester
ja ok klar leute auch das
selbstverständlich eine verhaltensweise
von sina die wir alle irgendwo irgendwie
nachvollziehen
also ich meine die eigene mutter hat
einen wieder so sehr damit genervt
einfach dadurch dass sie existiert und
scheinbar kein mensch ist und etwa ein
geist der in essen bringen
da muss man natürlich erstmal seinen
vier jahre jüngeren und deutlich
kleineren bruder körperlich misshandelt
selbstverständlich die 16 jährige kennt
keine skrupel
aber wir haben so wovon ist sie
gestresst
bevor das sie gestresst dass sie ihre
aggressionen rauslassen muss von war es
vom nicht zur schule gehen oder wie vom
vom sekt trinken vom ganzen bürger bei
merkels kauft und dann nicht mal rein
weißen die 16 jährige kennt keine
skrupel wenn sie geld für alkohol
zigaretten oder partys braucht beklaut
sie ihre mutter brach ab
ich will dass gerade mal bildlich hier
in worte fassen ok-chef vor dieser gomez
deutschland dann durch die tür
so kam tschechien polen österreich weist
solche analysen reichen
die sache schlechtes gewissen
fehlanzeige meine mutter mir nichts
gehen will dann denke ich mir dass ihr
problem ich nehme es mir einfach mal
junge es ist wirklich schmerzhaft leute
oder wird es ist schon hart genug dass
man so ein so kleiner teufel ist und
seinen eltern so eine harte zeit macht
aber diese frechheit einerseits zu sagen
so meine mutter märkte andererseits sich
aber an dem geld was die eigenen eltern
verdienen mit ihrer arbeit zu bedienen
einfach so weil hat man ja einfach
verdient als 16-jährige missgeburt das
ist echt schon das schon 30 sina in
einigen jahren im restmüll das was von
dem immer lauter nächste video kommt in
zwei tagen denn die beiden pascal und
sina werden in den dschungeln geschickt
bin mal gespannt wenn sie da bekommen
wollen bis dahin könnt ihr falls ihr
nicht aus deutschland kommt einfach mal
darüber nachdenkt ob hoogerland sina
aufnehmen mit oder pascal
vorstellungsvideo checken hier oben ein
kanal abonnieren weil ich dieses wieder
unterhalten hat das hat mich sehr freuen